>>> WELCOME BA TO OUR SPECIAL
ELECTION COVERAGE, BACK WITH
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN ADAM
KINZINGER.
SO CONGRESSMAN, IT'S UNCLEAR
OBVIOUSLY WHO WILL ULTIMATELY
WIN CONTROL OF CONGRESS.
WHAT IS CLEAR IS THAT THERE WAS
NO RED WAVE.
DO YOU THINK REPUBLICAN LEADERS
ARE REASSESSING THE ROLE THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS IN THE FUTURE
OF THE PARTY?
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY, IF THEY ARE EVER
GOING TO DO THAT, THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT?
>> WELL, I HOPE SO.
I WAS HERE ON JANUARY 7th
BASICALLY THINKING THAT THIS WAS
THE TIME TO REASSESS WHETHER OR
NOT DONALD TRUMP WAS THE FUTURE
OF THE PARTY.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, THE QUESTION
THAT REMAINS IS, SO DONALD TRUMP
IS GOING TO THROW KEVIN McCARTHY
UNDER THE BUS.
I'M JUST LIKE, PUT THAT DOWN IN
RED RIGHT NOW, AND UNDER LINE
IT, THE MAGA BASE IS GOING TO
THROW THIS ON KEVIN McCARTHY.
THE QUESTION IS DOES THE REST OF
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE THE COURAGE
TO STAND UP TO TRUMP OR DO THEY
ACQUIESCE TO HIM.
WE KNOW HE'S NOT GOING TO TAKE
THE BLAME FOR THIS, AT LEAST IN
HIS OWN MIND.
THIS IS CERTAINLY A REJECTION OF
THE MAGA BASE.
IT'S ALSO A HUGE MESSAGE THAT
CANDIDATE QUALITY MATTERS AND I
THINK IN WISCONSIN, THIS IS A
MESSAGE TO DEMOCRATS, I THINK A
MODERATE DEMOCRAT WOULD HAVE
CRUSHED RON JOHNSON IN WISCONSIN
BECAUSE HE'S ONE OF THE MORE
DISLIKED REPUBLICAN SENATORS.
CLOSE RACE, BUT I THINK A
MODERATE COULD HAVE DONE THAT.
>> GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS
OBVIOUSLY WON BIG IN FLORIDA,
GETTING A LOT OF LATINO VOTES.
DO YOU THINK, I MEAN, DO YOU SEE
HIM AS THE FUTURE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> YEAH, WELL, I DON'T.
BUT I THINK, YOU KNOW, CERTAINLY
HE'S PROBABLY IN THE LEAD RIGHT
NOW KIND OF IN A BIT OF A FRONT
RUNNER STATUS.
AGAIN, I THINK WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE OVER THE NEXT WEEK IS HOW
DOES DONALD TRUMP PIVOT FROM
THIS, BECAUSE HE'S CERTAINLY NOT
GOING TO TAKE HIS LOSS.
HE'S GOING TO TRY TO THROW
DeSANTIS UNDER THE BUS AND GO
AFTER McCARTHY.
IF HE'S ABLE TO DO THAT
SUCCESSFULLY, AND HE HAS OVER
THE LAST FEW TIMES, RON DeSANTIS
IS GOING TO HAVE A SHORT-LIVED
VICTORY HERE.
IT'S IMPORTANT, RON DeSANTIS
WINNING BIG WAS HUGE, AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO HIM, IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY A MESSAGE THAT WE
SAW LAST NIGHT THAT THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY WANTS NECESSARILY
RON DeSANTIS TYPE, I GUESS,
LEADERSHIP I'LL CALL IT.
I THINK HE HAS A REAL
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION TO WIN THE
PRESIDENCY, BUT IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE KIND OF THIS IN YOUR FACE
THING THAT WE'VE SEEN FROM
DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS WHAT WE SAW LAST NIGHT.
>> THERE'S REALLY A WARNING TO
THE WHITE HOUSE AS WELL IN THESE
VOTES.
I MEAN, WE'VE HEARD, YOU KNOW,
HEARD FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYING THERE'S A SENSE OF
VINDICATION, I THINK WAS THE
WORD THAT ONE SOURCE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE USED.
HOW DO YOU VIEW HOW THE WHITE
HOUSE SHOULD HANDLE WHAT
HAPPENED MOVING FORWARD?
I MEAN, WHAT IS THE LESSON FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE, WHAT IS THE
LESSON FOR THE REPUBLICANS?
>> YEAH, I THINK THERE'S NO
DOUBT LAST NIGHT WAS WAY BETTER
THAN WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE
EXPECTED.
IT'S WAY BETTER THAN WHAT
HISTORY EVER POINTS TO, AND I
THINK THEY SHOULD FEEL GOOD
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED LAST NIGHT.
YOU KNOW, LOOK, FOR ALL THE HITS
THAT PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, HIT JOE
BIDEN WITH, I MEAN, HE'S HAD A
LOT OF VICTORIES, AND LAST NIGHT
WAS ONE OF THOSE.
BUT I THINK THE REALITY IS YOU
STILL HAVE -- THIS CANNOT BE A
LESSON TO DEMOCRATS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO ADDRESS INFLATION,
WE DON'T HAVE TO ADDRESS CRIME,
WE DON'T HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THE
BORDER.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
I THINK A LOT OF THESE
CANDIDATES WON DESPITE THAT
STILL BEING A BIG ISSUE.
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO 2024,
THAT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT.
NOW, WHAT WILL BE INTERESTING,
ANDERSON, IS IF THERE'S JUST A
VERY VERY SLIM REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, THIS IS LIKE
WAY OUT OF LEFT FIELD, BUT THERE
IS A POSSIBILITY, THEN, IF YOU
CAN GET TWO REPUBLICANS, FOR
INSTANCE, TO VOTE FOR A CERTAIN
CANDIDATE AND GET THE DEMOCRATS
TO VOTE FOR A MODERATE
REPUBLICAN TYPE SPEAKER, YOU
COULD HAVE A REALLY INTERESTING
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE RACE.
I'M NOT PREDICTING IT, I'M
THROWING THAT IN PEOPLE'S EARS.
IF IT'S THAT TYPE, WE COULD DO
SOMETHING PRETTY UNUSUAL ON
THAT.
>> ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUINGS,
FELLOW MILITARY VETERAN, ELAINE
LURIA EXPECTED TO LOSE HER
ELECTION BID IN VIRGINIA, I
WONDER WHAT YOUR REACTION TO
THAT IS, OBVIOUSLY THE SAME
THING HAPPENED TO CONGRESSWOMAN
LIZ CHENEY IN HER PRIMARY THIS
SUMMER.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, ELAINE WILL BE
THE BEST TO TELL IF THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE HAD AN IMPACT ON
THAT.
I'LL SAY THIS ABOUT HER, LOOK,
IT'S, YOU KNOW, SHE'S A FELLOW
VETERAN.
IT'S BEEN GREAT WORKING WITH
HER.
SHE'S SOMEBODY THAT GENUINELY
CARES FOR HER COUNTRY.
WE, YOU KNOW, RAN ONE OF THE
LAST HEARINGS TOGETHER, AND I'M
SAD FOR THE COUNTRY THAT SHE
LOST.
AT THE SAME TIME, LOOK, SHE
STOOD UP FOR THE RIGHT THING.
VERY FEW PEOPLE EVER GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY STAND UP
FOR THE RIGHT THING.
EVEN FEWER ACTUALLY DO IT.
SHE GETS TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR,
AND I'LL TELL YOU, THERE'S NO
VICTORY, NO LOSS, NO ANYTHING
THAT I THINK CAN COMPARE TO
EITHER THE SHAME OF HAVING TO
LOOK IN THE MIRROR AND KNOW YOU
WENT ALONG WITH LIES OR THE
PRIDE OF BEING ABLE TO LOOK IN
THE MIRROR AND SAY JOU STOOD
ALONE.
I THINK SHE CAN TAKE THAT PRIDE
HOME.
>> ASSUMING THE FORMER PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCES HE'S GOING TO RUN,
THERE IS REPORTING HE MIGHT
ANNOUNCE THAT NEXT WEEK, WHAT
HAPPENS THEN IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY?
I MEAN, WHAT ARE THE RIPPLE
EFFECTS OF THAT IMMEDIATELY?
>> THIS IS THE MILLION DOLLAR
QUESTION.
THERE IS A SMALL POSSIBILITY
THAT IF HE MAKES THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT SOMEBODY LIKE A RON
DeSANTIS OR EVEN MIKE PENCE OR
WHATEVER COULD JUMP IN AND YOU
COULD HAVE A REAL BATTLE, YOU
KNOW, FOR THE SOUL OF THE PARTY.
IT'S JUST, AGAIN, THOUGH, THERE
IS SUCH A -- THE BASE IS SO
RABID FOR DONALD TRUMP, THE MAGA
BASE, AT LEAST, THAT I DON'T
THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE LONG
FOR HIM TO BE ABLE TO KIND OF
PERRY THE ATTACK, PUT IT ON
McCARTHY, PUT IT ON ANYBODY BUT
HIMSELF AND ONCE AGAIN COW TOE
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE, QUOTE
UNQUOTE LEADERS THAT DON'T KNOW
HOW TO LEAD, BACK TO I'M IN THE
DONALD TRUMP CAMP BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO LOSE THEIR
PRIMARY.
KEEP IN MIND, EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
A BAD NIGHT FOR REPUBLICANS,
YOU'RE STILL GOING TO HAVE A LOT
OF ELECTION DENIERS COMING TO
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
RIGHT NOW, EVEN PEOPLE THAT ARE
BORDERLINE OPEN WHITE
SUPREMACISTS, THIS WILL BE
INTERESTING.
I'M VERY INTERESTED, BY THE WAY
IN THE LAUREN BOEBERT RACE,
NOBODY SAW THAT ONE BEING AS
CLOSE AS IT IS, AND SHE VERY
WELL MAY LOSE IN COLORADO.
>> CONGRESSMAN ADAM KINZINGER,
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.